you may have noticed that overwatch
released last week and already Blizzard
has banned a surprisingly large number
of players more than 1500 in China have
been kicked out permanently and players
have posted on popular hacking forums
that they can't seem to trick blizzards
cheat detection I'm Lucy and welcome to
your band gamespot news update so 1572
band players in china were called out by
username on blizzard's forums a pc gamer
has posted screenshots of western
websites full of forum posts their
detailed cheaters failed attempts at
playing the game with hacks one player
claimed they were banned and after re
buying the game and playing fairly for a
couple of days they were banned again
the software they had used previously
was likely detected on their PC after
going through a process of changing
their mac address processor ID data and
other information they tried again
however they were banned once again
without using any methods of cheating or
hacking the player notes that Blizzard
mighta file registry marked his computer
which means they'll likely have to
reinstall the OS to get around it they
said so i guess i need to say goodbye to
this game I regret poking around d3d11
during the beta Blizzard takes cheating
seriously as evidenced by one person who
posted a screenshot of an account
closure email they received from the
developer the email reads we don't take
this decision lightly our team issued
this closure after a careful review of
relevant evidence our support staff will
not overturn these closures and may not
respond to Appeals so the lesson here
seems to be you shouldn't cheat not even
once hopefully you already knew that how
are you finding overwatch use your
favorite hero let me know in the
comments below I'll come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games for more
on overwatch keep it gamespot
you